en moins d'une heure toutes les parties
en fumée les cuisines les murs en bois
les chaises les tables
il ne reste presque rien de la paillote
avril 1999 dans la nuit du 19 au 20 un
incendie ravage la paillote chez francis
construite dans l'illégalité sur le
domaine public maritime corse
un incendie qui n'avait rien
d'accidentel pour le propriétaire
vous pensez que c'est de la jalousie oui
parce que on a trouvé des papiers ferro
bancho flics et de chocolat gens mangent
pas dès le début de l enquête la piste
criminelle se dessine au vu de plusieurs
indices laissés sur place
les soupçons se dirigent vers des
gendarmes auditionné puis placé en garde
à vue trois militaires finissent par
avouer avoir participé à une mission
spéciale
nous ce qu'on voudrait savoir ce qui a
donné l'ordre parce que ces trois
gendarmes si brillant soit-il ont reçu
un ordre mais qui a donné l'ordre
très vite le colonel de gendarmerie
henry mazères est pointé du doigt
ainsi que le préfet bernard bonnet
nommer un an plus tôt après l'assassinât
de claude erignac
connu pour sa fermeté il est nommé par
le gouvernement qui espèrent ainsi
rétablir l'état de droit sur l'île les
paillotes qui occupe illégalement le
littoral était dans le viseur du nouveau
préfet il faut arrêter de s'approprier à
des fins privées sans aucune
autorisation
le littoral nous avons mille kilomètres
de côtes ce qui est un atout
considérable pour la corse pour son
image pour son développement
organisons le
quelques semaines après l incendie le
colonel mazères et le préfet bonnet sont
placés en garde à vue et suspendus de
leurs fonctions
à la veille de leur procès ils
s'accusaient mutuellement quasiment tous
les soirs au cours de la réunion
toujours ce sujet revenait quand est-ce
que
vous détruisez la période suivante 6
l'ordre le colonel mazères reconnaît
l'avoir donné mazères est persuadé à ce
moment là évidemment de manière non
orthodoxes peut pas l'approuver
on a vu les conséquences mais
d'appliquer une décision de justice et
en aucune façon de commettre une
infraction pénale
bernard bonnet accusé même le
gouvernement d'être impliqué dans la
sphère le 9 avril 1999 une incitation au
passage à l'acte a été fait
effectivement par matignon voit l'armée
mais où on savait en bas on savait mais
vous ne saviez pas et vous disposerez
plusieurs personnes seront condamnés
dans la sphère des paillotes corse
bernard bonnet désigné comme
l'instigateur des faits écopera lui de
trois ans de prison dont un ferme et
trois ans de privation de ses droits
civiques
s'il reconnaissait les faits l'ancien
préfet continuera d'évoquer un complot
politico judiciaire dont il a été la
victime
[Musique]